20h la nuit tombe et le hameau fournaise
de Chatou s'illumine pour cette
troisième édition le festival des
lumières impressionnistes inviter les
passants à voyager vers le Japon car au
XIXe siècle les estampes japonaises ont
largement inspiré les impressionnistes
et donc on a créé des diptyque qui
permettent aux gens en fait de repérer
les similitudes dans les constructions
et c'est tout ce que le festival a voulu
mettre en œuvre en fait à travers le son
et lumière les spectacles c'est de
montrer à quel point le Japon était une
influence féconde sur la culture
française à la fin du 19e et puis de
quelle manière aussi le Japon s'est
inspiré de la France donc vraiment c'est
le dialogue des cultures qu'on met à
l'honneur le tout sur un site
entièrement décoré avec des lampions
japonais des nénus phares lumineux et
des centaines de lumières des spectacles
des acrobaties étaient également au
programme on est sur un festival
impressionniste plus calme plus poétique
plus familiale aussi de plus en plus
important parce qu'on a on a la première
année on a été vraiment victime de
succès on pensait pas on a eu plus de
6000 personnes et c'est vrai que l'an
dernier autant pour time on va dire pas
très pas très moyen cet événement festif
est gratuit est en accès libre
rendez-vous l'année prochaine début
septembre pour contempler un nouveau
spectacle lumineux sur l'île des
Impressionnistes